five hundred
sixty seven thousand seven hundred and
fifteen
that's how many homeless people the u.s
department of housing and urban
development
counted on a cold january night in 2019.
more than half a million americans are
homeless on any given night
but on the west coast the problem has
grown worse in recent years
things haven't improved with the coven
19 pandemic in 2020
homelessness is on the rise in america
san francisco is rushing to contain a
coronavirus outbreak that hit its
biggest homeless shelter the homeless
population in the county is up 13
percent from last year
as the city of l.a saw a 14 jump
homelessness is growing
and governments have done
too little too late
there's no doubt that the homeless are
stigmatized and all too often we
conflate the issue with mental health
or we just blame the victim most people
blame homelessness on the person
that it's they're a bum or they're lazy
or they made bad decisions if
homelessness was a punishment for bad
decisions we'd all be homeless but this
is a complex
issue and no two stories are alike there
are actually
a huge range of forces that
often kind of come together and compound
one another when it comes to how an
individual
falls into homelessness but how did we
get here how did a nation
with such wealth and prosperity wind up
with half a million people on the
streets
and more importantly what can we do
about it it really is an urgent problem
and there's no reason
that we shouldn't fix it i zoomed in
with a journalist
two non-profit execs and a formally
displaced activist
to better understand the confounding
issue of america's homeless
before we can understand american
homelessness we need to know a little
bit about its origins
in america a lot of scholars look to the
period immediately following the civil
war
as the emergence of homelessness a lot
of veterans were returning from the war
and returning to very overcrowded you
know industrializing cities
that were very short on housing ever
since then there's been a population of
people
in america who have not necessarily fit
into the sort of
standard economic narrative fields like
logging
fishing mining they wouldn't really have
what we would think of as a stable home
many people who were
what we would call homeless actually did
have shelter
in places like single room occupancy
apartments and hotels
um in what they would call flop houses
in the 1950s and 60s there was
at that time urban renewal in cities so
they were just numerically speaking a
lot fewer of these sort of
transitional very inexpensive housing
options
a lot of low-income minority
neighborhoods in american cities
were ripped apart a lot of the housing
that existed in those neighborhoods
was also gone you have more
de-institutionalization
of people experiencing mental illness
starting in the late 70s and 80s the
department of housing and urban
development
is getting defunded to a significant
degree and then just
de-industrialization
and rising economic inequality created a
more
a larger population of people that are
sort of living in extreme poverty
now that of course is a very abridged
version of the history of american
homelessness
but the main takeaway seems to be that
there is no one cause of the problem
the reason that people fall into
homelessness is that
there's basically a series of
unfortunate events that
befall them some of those include losing
a job
they include domestic violence that's a
leading
issue for women in particular and
families returning from war
and experiencing post-traumatic stress
losing
benefits whether health care or welfare
having a health problem that costs a
huge amount of money
and bankrupts somebody if you mix one of
those things
or you know add multiple of those forces
together
add in addiction or mental health issues
while a multitude of factors can and do
contribute to homelessness
what it really boils down to is right in
the name
homes the truth is the leading cause of
homelessness is the lack of affordable
housing
people are not earning enough money to
pay for the housing that's available
essentially
there are approximately 11 million
low-income renters in america
research from the federal reserve found
that 59
of americans are one paycheck away from
being homeless
for every 10 of the lowest income
renters
there's fewer than four apartments that
are affordable to them
and so because there's such a shortage
we have
nearly eight million of the lowest
income renter
households families who are paying at
least half of their income
towards their rent and many are paying
much more they're paying
60 70 80 of their income just to keep a
roof
over their heads so it's sort of like a
game of musical chairs
um you have the chairs the chairs are
getting pulled away
and they're just more people than there
are chairs to sit in coven 19 has proven
to be
the straw that broke the camel's back
for many of these struggling households
i would say that coveted 19 has
exacerbated
the underlying crisis of affordable
housing
and the tremendous racial disparities in
who is most
harmed by the housing crisis when you
have such limited income to begin with
and you're paying so much of it to keep
a roof over your head
you're always one financial shock
away from missing rent and potentially
facing eviction and in worse cases
becoming homeless
so for many of these same households
the coronavirus is that financial
emergency
they've lost jobs they've lost hours at
work they've lost wages
it's harder than ever for them to cobble
together what they need to make rent
a columbia university economist
predicted a 40 to 45 percent increase in
homelessness by the end of 2020
this is due to both the newly displaced
as well as the strain coven 19 has put
on existing homeless communities covet
has had
definitely had an effect on the
homelessness system shelters
have had to follow the cdc guidance on
social distancing so
they've essentially had to decompress or
thin out
their shelters they can't serve as many
people often they're serving half the
number of people that they used to serve
but there is a silver lining here cloven
19 while devastating
has demonstrated what's possible when we
mobilize to help the most vulnerable
among us
there's also now a lot more creative
thinking
around what to do to create more housing
and more opportunities for
safe places for homeless people to to
stay there's been
more of an embrace of sanctioned
encampments
which are essentially places where
local governments set up security and
bathrooms and facilities to help
and then allow homeless people to come
the other big thing is hotels were
emptied out
because tourists disappeared during
covid and so
a lot of cities started housing homeless
people in in those empty hotels
hundreds of men have moved from homeless
shelters to a fancy hotel
i called the lucerne hotel they said
they are not taking reservations
until at least december it seems like
that was
a pretty successful way to actually
prevent mass outbreaks among the
homeless population
one thing the coronavirus has shown is
that governments
if they want to can work with homeless
service providers
and increase the urgency
and create programs to get people off
the streets
but clearly we as a country
are not doing enough we can end
homelessness
we actually know how to end homelessness
and we've known how to end homelessness
for a long time the problem is there's
not the public
and political will to push
all the policy change forward to
create more affordable housing and to
create
programs in support of housing to get
homeless people
off the streets in the numbers that we
need
to get them off the streets to end
homelessness
i think there is a widespread sense
among people who work
in homelessness services that there
isn't enough
money devoted to this and
the the top line answer is that
it's such a big and complicated problem
that there are several
levers that need to be pulled from a
policy perspective
there's generally bipartisan
understanding
that we have a homelessness crisis that
is unacceptable
there's generally a bipartisan
understanding that we have a shortage
of affordable apartments for the lowest
income people
where there tends to be a split is
whether
there's a willingness to fund the
investments that are needed to
alleviate the problems the major way
that you're going to end homelessness by
getting people into housing as quickly
as possible
and since these are very poor people and
they can't afford
most housing we're going to need housing
subsidies
to accomplish that many many people the
majority of people who become homeless
actually do exit homelessness they get
back on their feet
they find a job and they don't enter the
homeless system again
and it's not a long-term lifetime
sentence
being homeless so we have to remember
that it's something that for most people
is a shorter term experience
you